tampa bay buccaneers now this has not
yet been posted by points bet but
they've informed us that when the lines
are out for all 17 games the buccaneers
will be favored to win
each one of them that happened in 2019
the patriots were favored before the
season to win all 16 of their games and
remember they were like 8-0 i think
before a sunday night night game against
the ravens and the ravens gave them
their first loss and they finished 12-4
but the buccaneers with tom brady in his
second year with the team
will be favored to win
all 17 of the games that you see there
on the screen
yeah i think the their their one against
the rams is probably gonna be the
closest and look it's it's gonna be
interesting to see what they do look i i
think by the end of the season
the buccaneers were clearly the best
team in football and when you return all
22 starters and then a lot of your key
guys that are reserves there's no reason
to think that they shouldn't be favored
in all 17 of these games so
i mean i do i think that they're gonna
be able to go 17-0 no not necessarily
but i think that it's going to be fun to
watch them for most of the year and can
they go
15 and 2 or 14 and 3 yeah i don't see
why that's impossible
the
fact that the rams game will be the
smallest line right now one and a half
is what is expected to come in at that's
the last game before
tom brady goes back to new england and
look i
i would suspect that he's probably the
last person on earth to be distracted by
anything he's the king of focus and
compartmentalization and doing what
needs to be done now
but
he's never experienced
going back to gillette stadium the place
where he'd been for 20 years
knowing it's looming knowing it's there
how do you set that aside how do you
focus on a cross-country trip to la to
play the rams take care of business
there and then all the way back to tampa
and get ready for that game in new
england that it's unprecedented for him
for anyone in the nfl to to have that
marker week four
that's there and potentially distracting
you so we'll see what that means when
they play the la rams but let's talk
about that uh
that week four game tom brady made the
point yesterday
in response to a graphic showing him
back at gillette stadium in his
buccaneers uniform it's like when your
high school friends
meet your college friends
with the i don't know what that is emoji
i don't know how to describe it is it
scared emoji what is it i would call it
more of a drama
like
you know fake cheesy fake smile emoji i
don't know but uh i'm gonna date myself
with this one it's like and i love lucy
you know where she's like uh
you know that's kind of how i how i
picture it
wait but you weren't even i was lucy
even alive when you were alive is there
any over my mom might not make a lucy
reference i know my mom i don't think
was alive when that show started coming
on the air so
like
you know you watch it uh you know they
used to show it on nick at night the
place for tv hits you know
louise i love lucy yeah the one where
she's getting the chocolates off the
conveyor belt it's classic stuff man
they're playing the old-time music for
miles he's not even 30 yet
they're playing the old-time music they
haven't played and i don't want to see
those single-digit numbers either get
off my lawn
um so anyway the game between the
patriots and the buccaneers week four
gillette stadium it's expected to be
a record
price
on the secondary market and it's just so
funny how
it's like a a switch flip somewhere
like my whole life up until i don't know
15 years ago scalping illegal scalping
wrong scalping improper scalping hey
it's cool man as long as the nfl can get
their cut it's great everybody's
scalping now you do it on a computer
it's fine you stand outside the stadium
not fine do it do it in your phone hey
man open season so anyway uh so the
tickets are expected to go for
uh
more than fifteen hundred dollars right
now
the cheapest seat on ticketmaster is
fifteen hundred dollars uh it's just
crazy and i suspect miles it's only
going to go up and up as the event gets
closer
oh no doubt because look if you are
somebody who rooted for tom brady for so
many years saw him win so many trophies
you'll want to come back and you want to
you want to give him his due i would
just expect right i don't feel like tom
brady's gonna come in there and that
people are gonna like boo tom brady why
would anybody ever do that he won you
literally six trophies so is even though
he went to tampa bay and he won another
like
they're gonna honor tom brady probably
in a significant way uh on the video
board you know by the pregame something
is gonna happen to honor tom brady and i
really understand why fans would wanna
be in the stands for what is probably
going to be his last time ever at
foxborough as a player
what is the most miles that you would
pay a ticket to see
and what is it that you would pay that
amount for
that's a really good question man uh
i two grand probably
and but i would have to be like in a
really good sea i'm just gonna pay two
grand just to be in the in the stadium
like if it's two grand and i'm like
front and center for the red hot chili
peppers especially because john
freschenty's back
that would probably oh john for shenty
well absolutely john freschente who
who could who could ever spend less than
than two dimes to go see john freschente
you know i i don't understand it miles i
don't understand it miles you can spend
two grand to go see a group that was
popular in the 80s man and and and
you're still eating at breakfast buffet
something doesn't add up here
i don't know i think and i'm making i
love lucy references i think i just aged
myself like
20 years of the course of this show but
you know if you're saying it like that
you don't understand how good that man
is at guitar all right it's a big deal
that he's back it's a big big deal
i've never even heard of him i know it's
of anthony uh keitis is that his last
name and
yes and chat smith on the drums
yeah beyond that i don't know i don't
know okay um all right i i don't know i
don't know what i would
i don't know how much i'd pay for
something i'm extremely cheap it would
have to be something really really great
something really awesome
the final kiss concert ever what would
you pay no i don't care i don't care
that that ship has sailed i was there
two years ago i mean they should no no
it's time for walkers and and crutches
it's it's it's it's not what it was if i
if it doesn't matter
it's yeah it matters trust me i saw him
when they could actually move around on
those boots it's not it's not good
anymore it really isn't they distract
you with lights and images and and bombs
and
you know the older they get the more
fire they incorporate into their act
because it's a distraction from the fact
that you know uh
it's it's just not spandex is not kind
to the uh to the body of a man in his
70s that's for sure so uh
i i don't know i you know i've never
seen springsteen
and i've become a springsteen guy i know
that that all middle-aged reporters are
you know springsteen guys their entire
life
you are a white sports writer i i just
but i did just discover him within the
past couple of years we went to see him
on broadway when he was doing the one
man show which was awesome and uh i've
been listening to a lot of springsteen
the past two or three years so i'd want
to see one of his legendary three-hour e
street band conferences or conference
concerts not conferences slight
difference between the two words first
three letters are the same though but
that's what i i would probably pay a lot
to you know to be close enough to see
his 70 year old body not in spandex
he'll stick with you know blue jeans and
uh and a jean jacket or something that'd
probably be a good concert if we're
talking about like older people i would
say elton john i would spend a lot of
money to go see elton john probably you
know billy joel probably another one of
those guys that i just want to see i did
see the rolling stones a few years ago
and i was supposed to see them last year
before the pandemic but like you know
that would be another one where i would
spend some good money probably just
because you know you want to be able to
see those people before they kick the
bucket
week nine of the regular season and i
assume that there will be some demand
for this ticket in carolina
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports